Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to listen to some amazing
improvements in the area of AI-based voice
cloning.
For instance, if someone wanted to clone my
voice, there are hours and hours of my voice
recordings on Youtube and elsewhere, they
could do it with previously existing techniques.
But the question today is, if we had even
more advanced methods to do this, how big
of a sound sample would we really need for
this?
Do we need a few hours?
A few minutes?
The answer is no.
Not at all.
Hold on to your papers because this new technique
only requires 5 seconds.
Let’s listen to a couple examples.
Absolutely incredible.
The timbre of the voice is very similar, and
it is able to synthesize sounds and consonants
that have to be inferred because they were
not heard in the original voice sample.
This requires a certain kind of intelligence
and quite a bit of that.
So, while we are at that, how does this new
system work?
Well, it requires three components.
One, the speaker encoder is a neural network
that was trained on thousands and thousands
of speakers and is meant to squeeze all this
learned data into a compressed representation.
In other words, it tries to learn the essence
of human speech from many many speakers.
To clarify, I will add that this system listens
to thousands of people talking to learn the
intricacies of human speech, but this training
step needs to be done only once, and after
that, it was allowed just 5 seconds of speech
data from someone they haven’t heard of
previously, and later, the synthesis takes
place using this 5 seconds as an input.
Two, we have a synthesizer that takes text
as an input, this is what we would like our
test subject to say, and it gives us a Mel
Spectrogram, which is a concise representation
of someone’s voice and intonation.
The implementation of this module is based
on DeepMind’s Tacotron 2 technique, and
here you can see an example of this Mel spectrogram
built for a male and two female speakers.
On the left, we have the spectrograms of the
reference recordings, the voice samples if
you will, and on the right, we specify a piece
of text that we would like the learning algorithm
to utter, and it produces these corresponding
synthesized spectrograms.
But, eventually, we would like to listen to
something, and for that, we need a waveform
as an output.
So, the third element is thus a neural vocoder
that does exactly that, and this component
is implemented by DeepMind’s WaveNet technique.
This is the architecture that led to these
amazing examples.
So how do we measure exactly how amazing it
is?
When we have a solution, evaluating it is
also anything but trivial.
In principle, we are looking for a result
that is both close to the recording that we
have of the target person, but says something
completely different, and all this in a natural
manner.
This naturalness and similarity can be measured,
but we’re not nearly done yet, because the
problem gets even more difficult.
For instance, it matters how we fit the three
puzzle pieces together, and then, what data
we train on, of course, also matters a great
deal.
Here you see that if we train on one dataset
and test the results against a different one,
and then, swap the two, and…the results
in naturalness and similarity will differ
significantly.
The paper contains a very detailed evaluation
section that explains how to deal with these
difficulties.
The mean opinion score is measured in this
section, which is a number that describes
how well a sound sample would pass as genuine
human speech.
And we haven’t even talked about the speaker
verification part, so make sure to have a
look at the paper.
So, indeed, we can clone each other’s voice
by using a sample of only 5 seconds.
What a time to be alive!
This episode has been supported by Weights
& Biases.
Weights & Biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning projects.
It can save you a ton of time and money in
these projects and is being used by OpenAI,
Toyota Research, Stanford and Berkeley.
They also wrote a guide on the fundamentals
of neural networks where they explain in simple
terms how to train a neural network properly,
what are the most common errors you can make,
and how to fix them.
It is really great, you got to have a look.
So make sure to visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!